Let's summarise some of the main points from
this lecture.
We talked about how a robot knows where objects
are in its environment. A robot doesn't actually
measure the position of its tool tip, it is
inferred from joint angle measurements and
from a kinematic model. It knows the Cartesian
coordinate of where the tool tip needs to
go in the world, and it’s the job of the
motion controller to take the tool tip there.
A number of things can go wrong with this
process; there could be errors in the sensors,
there could be errors in the kinematic model,
we may not know the base position of the robot
accurately, we may not know the location of
the circuit board very accurately. All of
these issues have consequences on the way
we construct a modern industrial robot and
they generally tend to lead to increased cost.
We can contrast that with the way human beings
solve problems; for instance threading a needle.
I use my eyes to guide or to steer the end
of the thread through the hole in the needle.
If we consider this problem a bit more schematically
where we're trying to align the end of two
objects, we can consider the task in the three-dimensional
Cartesian space and we can also look at that
task with a camera. We can look at a two-dimensional
representation of that task being achieved.
We talked about how using information from
just a single image actually provides insufficient
information to reliably perform this task
in three-dimensional space. But we can actually
perform the task simultaneously in two camera
views, aligning the red and blue objects,
and if that happens, then in the real three-dimensional world the red and blue objects will also become aligned.
We talked about what happens when we move
a camera. The camera's got six degrees of
freedom; its velocity can be described in
terms of three translational velocity components
and three rotational velocity components.
If we imagine that the camera is looking at
a regular array of points a constant distance
away, then each of the camera velocity components
results in a fairly unique pattern of motion
of those points on the image plane. And here
we can see the patterns of motion, which are
referred to as optical flow, due to velocity
in the X direction, velocity in the Z direction
or rotational velocity around the Z axis.
The patterns are fairly distinct but some
of them are a little bit similar, and in particular
velocity in the X direction is quite similar
to the pattern of motion induced by rotation
around the Y axis; they look quite similar,
but the amount of similarity actually depends
on the focal length of the lens. For a large
focal length, the ambiguity is quite pronounced.
As the focal length gets smaller, the ambiguity
is much less evident. This ambiguity between
vX and omega-Y, we also see between vY and
omega-X, there's a symmetry there.
The relationship between the camera velocity
which is described by a six vector and the
velocity of the point on the image plane,
is described by the image Jacobian matrix.
The image Jacobian matrix tells us, for a
particular camera motion, how points will
move on the image plane. We can turn this
around and saying instead we want to have
a particular velocity on the image plane in
order to move a shape from perhaps an initial
view to a desired view. So now we have the
image plane velocity, we can invert the relationship
and determine the camera velocity that we need in order to achieve our desired view of the object.
The image Jacobian relates pixel velocity
to camera velocity, and the image Jacobian
itself is a function of many parameters. It
depends on the co-ordinate of the point on
the image plane, it depends on how far the
point is away from the camera in three-dimensional
space and it depends on the focal length.
We can re-arrange this equation in many different
ways; perhaps we know pixel velocity and Z,
and u and v, and then we can determine what
the camera velocity is. There are many tricks that we can play with this image Jacobian matrix.